2人もいるんだっけ
1人?
面白いよく知らないけど
すごいです
アミとタイキがエコエに入った時に
いろんな先生がいらっしゃって
1人の先生だけがアリシアみたいに
アフリカのカーだったのね
タイキもアミもその先生が一番好きでね
先生とっても不思議があってね
その子たちは自分が来てくれるんだって
私に好きになったって
そうよね
だからやっぱり小さい時からそういうの見てるのって
すごくいいと思う
リキちゃんだってそうよね
小さい時からいろいろんな日本人
アジア人の顔してる人とかいろんな人がいて
それ不思議じゃないじゃない?
だけど
メメンなんてやっぱりずっと
日本人しか見てなかったからね
変なさは思えなかったけど
まあそうした
コリウムも
フランクで学校行ってたことに
あったり
最初にフランクに住まって
生まれたから外国人っていうのも
知らなかったから
新婦様やっぱり
新婦様はドイツ人の新婦様とか
だったのね
精神です
野間田さん
ああそうな
精神の人
英語はちゃんとした
アイリシューとか
ね
どなたは知ってらっしゃる?
今いらっしゃるんでしょう
そうなんでしょ
いっぱい言われたけど
まだ吉川とか覚えてる?
あ、その
学校行ってたじゃないけど
校長さんもだったから
怖い
怖いまだ吉川
その時いらっしゃった
クエンティっていう
クエンティだった方ね
あの方はすごく私が好きで
私がね
こっちがね
すごく好きで
だけど英語ばっかり以上
話してくださるから
それは嫌で逃げてたのよ
分かんないから
困ってそれ
だけどあの
アメリカに
ニューヨークに行ってからね
長いお手紙書いたの
すごく喜んで
すごい長い返事くださって
オスエリアにいらっしゃってたの
そうなんで
全然